okay people joining this livestream we
are looking at unsupervised learning
machine learning functions and we are
hopefully in the final fairly final
stages of documenting new functions for
version 12 so we start let's go to the
guide page for these things right then
we can either start with anomaly
detection ones or with relearn
distribution ones
are we okay what we've got these
separate pages apparently for a machine
for unsupervised and let's let's go
there again um oh for goodness sake what
a silly thing um
she no name okay so I don't know what
these are unsupervised machine learning
supervised machine learning so we never
finished these pages
no okay and do we think um I mean I
think we probably want to break up this
big page into those right
and I think we've got on the route guide
page what do we have it do oh gosh this
is still not fixed
because Sushma you are you hear that how
come this this is still broken okay so
are we gonna add categories here by the
way oh it didn't work okay but but those
categories there are we gonna add things
to that top level category list
attend I think we probably should go
sorry going to see too much learning
okay so it wasn't paying attention
yeah unlike this I have no idea whether
the feature detection page looks like it
is um it's quite a bit we should be
adding to the Future detection page from
the anomalous stuff and so on right oh I
don't see where I normally would go in
feature detection all right
well but but shouldn't we have a page
specifically about um okay so from
machine learning shouldn't we have a
page specifically about anomaly
detection not making sense it's for
functions I mean for singles including
okay including things like delete
missing and all those kinds of things I
mean there are kind of similar in delete
missing it's quite different all right
okay okay fine so it could be a page
about unsupervised learning where we put
yeah Alan its distribution dimension
addiction feature extraction clustering
atom addiction and so on okay I think
that's what we had planned and I think
we should do that but let's go ahead and
look at these specific functions first
okay are we considering these
experimental for this version or not I
think so yes definitely definitely you
know it's it's the concept is good
so underline Alisha nothing is good we
might still need to you know fine-tune
some places it may be people just wanted
to delete anomalies without realizing
that underlying it's like a big mesh
running functions might not necessarily
understand you know expect this behavior
which behavior so it will okay typically
what I'm thinking is in low dimension
yeah I want to remove outliers our
paradigm yes
our paradigm is excellent for high
dimensional data set and when I say high
it can be you know let's say three and
more when you go in dimension one it's
bit less good wait something else we
need to get a bit dirty in a way like
it's a really clean principle that I
think works great in most cases but but
in one dimension it's my people might
expect more of a clustering type
algorithm we so we need to make it work
in one dimension and we need to make it
work so that we can use it okay fine all
it should be experimental okay
all right generates a specified property
you
well what do you mean it generates that
property so here it's got a return so
you can say I normally did take - all
right well what is what are the
properties no this is doing something
different this is this is doing is using
the detector yeah which is not what
we're doing
no when yeah so I don't understand that
second usage that it seems wrong to me
I don't know several second - so okay
this this use it is our typical in the
unsupervised learning functionality much
an addiction as it is because often when
you learn a dimension I mean when he
learns as a supervised model you have
for free the task that it was supposed
to do in the training data so for
dimension return for example yet when
you ask for reducer you could have for
free to reduce data most of the time so
it makes sense to be able to ask for
both of the properties okay for this
case it's cure to find the anomalies
when you have the anomaly detector we
should by the way works when given I
don't think we should have this and it's
doing the top usage message I think
they're very confusing you know what
that's fine I think there was our
original design because fine anomalies
does it families as these properties
where you can have a very position
nobody counts blah blah blah so I'm okay
and I think I mean it's okay as well
right I remember him telling that as
well all right let's picturise these or
should we tentative those
yes so should we just can't give them I
think it should tentative them and I
believe like the user if the user
doesn't know that there is a other
functions and just see anomaly detection
and doesn't want to spend that much time
searching for other functions to my
gonna solve that problem for them if
they can't be bothered to look find that
there's a go find anomalies not we can't
solve that problem by having an
elaborate design here but the moving
properties here because we are families
if we didn't have families there will be
another another story so we just go
ahead and delete these done I think we
should good so now further melis because
becomes kind of the main okay so make
sure the examples reflect that change
yep
so we are intending to automatically
recede is that the default no we don't
want two three four terrific yeah we're
calling it nominal or categorical we
started with nominal so we've been kind
of continuing okay it's everywhere long
now yeah okay
although a rickety record would have
been a better name what's that I mean I
think we should go through and change it
I I mean nominal reminds me of the
everything well I don't even understand
what it means it's like it reminds me of
like the you know that I'm sure what he
will be hearing because the 50th
anniversary the Apollo missions right
everything you know the such and such as
nominal means means the fuel tank hasn't
blown up yet or something okay
so Sushma that's a thing for you I think
we should figure out where nominal has
been used and try and change them okay
well it's not the central for right now
okay this looks good okay why aren't we
looking we should look find anomalies
should surely be the first thing that we
are pointing to from anomaly detection I
guess especially that now it's the main
one
you
should we anomaly detector function
should that be at the beginning there I
think it probably should be yeah maybe
in second or third
okay
looks good yep okay find anomalies
you
most of the example I that are
considered anomalous with respect to the
other examples
you
I think it's nice way to we can say
gives the specified property of
anomalies of the detected anomalies of
any anomalies to take it yeah yeah I
mean it could also be the non-anomalous
which is not really a property of the
detective it
okay gives the specified property of
the examples returned
No
properties McKinley anomalies anime
account billion mask not anomalies
positions even rarer probability okay I
understand okay okay well I'm not sure
that that's quite the specified property
well let's see are we sure we want to
call it property that's how we knew I
mean you know everywhere else okay
it gives the specified property over the
anomaly set that works
nobody said we'd what does it mean like
everything related to animal you know
nobody set of anomalies variability good
for each examples each example it says
how how much of an outlier is by this
metric you specify property well this is
obscure okay give us a list of example
either considered mammals with respect
to the other examples okay so it gives
it is a anomaly finding which is a
anomaly computation that's kind of weird
too um it's how long for fuzzy right
what you traitor
just related to the you know Jesus trip
already related to and then we say okay
so nobody computation or no Mary finding
or but it's bit more vague and I think
it's not very yeah that's what it is you
know
it is just related to that but when it
finds anomalies in data this isn't right
this last Mahamaya right what should
that one say it could be date tau or
examples oh no it could be one example
where many can it be mr. data actually
shouldn't be I mean we made it work
right with one example I mean yeah it
works dan of not so I mean because you
have anomalies you know brilliant mask
she's supposed to be at least all the
time
maybe the click data even you know if
somebody tries to with one example to
work as well but you know I'm convinced
the word you should just not make it
work for one example oh I can't see
okay so what happens if you want
properties in that last case you can put
two properties as well here yes so we we
forgot to okay come on it so
okay here okay gives the specified
property gosh how to say this I mean it
seems is such a well really computation
yeah we have like let's say in dimension
reduction we have these for example and
we said related to what we say dimension
reduction you said yeah you said related
to the reduction I think
let's see plus but all all the
dimensionality reduction your rights
prefer relating that case yeah I think
relation is better if you here it's okay
because that's actually you know those
are much more closely related okay
okay we need to have the final case here
right
you
yep
should we thing that really has the
I don't think we usually put it in that
explicit of form do we uh I don't know
it seemed natural for me but I asked
myself a question as well what will be
the analogous thing for dimension
reduction to mention reduced right
but we don't have you don't put the
reducer or feature and feature that
feature extract we do yes feature X no
we don't do that much we've kind of
started also in synthesize missing
values we put it first so you want to
put detect all but what was synthesized
missing values right yeah
we haven't reviewed yet but yeah this
one also you can have the learn
distribution this time as a first
argument you know you're just calling it
guessed I call it this here let's call
it func here
we should hmm make clear that Frankie's
is like is it a girl this what the
detector is anomaly detector function
yeah the analytical function Frank did
you like detector I don't know why I
wanted to put felt that we use that
somewhere American Idol American
icon it's kind of clear let's do it
it's now we have four lines should we
still separate the unique property and
many properties before sometimes we
don't do it sometimes we just write
props I depends on how commonly you want
one of them I think you might very well
want more than one I mean one of them or
more I think it's okay
you
you
okay so in this case here we'd say data
right yes
training examples for the detector same
distribution as a training examples okay
I guess that's right to dirt there's
travel when their error probability is
below why didn't that oh because Bello
is a perfectly good word
meter smarter um there's below this
below the value specified for acceptance
threshold yep not specified by I guess
for it's an interesting by the way
aspect on that uh normally the data
comes from send distribution right yeah
well and so it's really the anomaly
detection false positive right that
directly give
an idea for the value you should put an
excellent special actually that's really
that it's you Oh
- of warning a felon that passed the
filter wrongly
well weather yeah boolean values
indicating whether yeah which I think
it's maybe the food that was Emmy and I
remember us checking the spelling
boolean values
you
I think we should say anomaly positions
here and I don't think you should say
mask there's no masking happening
nobody's masked here um this was used
your ID Padre my idea well boolean lists
wait a minute we should say Oh decisions
okay in okay importantly in a detective
function since you can have typically
you have one element we just call it
decision is normally honored true forms
so we call it decision because it's in
the context that you already have a
detective function use it on a new
example and the decision is true or
false
is it an anomaly or not but maybe in the
context of fine anomalies you want
something different but I would be fine
with calling it just decisions which one
this one no this is totally obscure um
in this context again normally or not is
really what it is yeah um anomaly cue
normality um oh gosh come on what what
should we say here this is it's really
anomaly cue list anomaly q yes normally
Q yeah because it's a test
is it an anomaly Oh q okay but that's
obscure as well yeah um I normally count
um this should certainly be anomaly
positions we switch back and forth we
thought that in the context of an
anomaly is it was a bit repetitive but I
guess we say animal accounts so we have
to be if we're doing that because
otherwise we don't know whether it's
anomaly or non anomaly
um okay this is the same kind of list
that pic uses for example
what do we call such lists
I mean that's a correct name a
normlessness net list don't we have
animal duty another word I just thought
about it might be a worse
I can't think it is no there's no
official English what's that this
there's no official English contrary to
French it's not still working in France
the official killing French language for
hundreds of years
who invented that was that invented by
Napoleon or was that predate no no I
think it's some setting in a book club
you know and then some people you know I
mean in France we love to have norms for
everything like metric system and so on
and say oh let's make it official and
but people the language evolved when
people were speaking it but writing it
didn't involve because it was set in
stone so now we have kind of two
languages
I know people know how to write French
because we're speaking differently trust
me um okay I think a normlessness
list
is that okay you okay with that I mean
too big of a name with that's weird
our livestream is suggesting anomalous
selectors it's not quite right because
we're close
you
anomaly okay
another possibility we anomaly
true/false
and now we'll be indicator that's
reasonable amélie indicators that's
perfectly reasonable and notice that we
used the word indicating in the
right-hand side here which is a good
sign that's the right name that's good
okay
I noticed that we're not in alphabetical
order anymore here but we will sort the
table to get ourselves there
okay probably to generate a sample that
has a lower PDF then
the given data
the given data right but it's not
examples anymore it's this case here
right it could be the examples as well
if you safe anomalies if any nominees
include examples you can still ask for
our probability still figure out what is
the underlying distribution okay hold on
probably generate a sample that has a
lower PDF
so that what we said but as a
probability generative sample so you can
go to write a probability is a page I
don't think we reviewed it it's always a
tricky thing to explain that
you
that shouldn't be a link PDF it's you
know okay it's actually not necessarily
a PDF it could be also a probability
mass so it's called probability mass or
probabilities we just
okay we're late it has a lower PDF than
example it's the probability for
distribution to generate a sample yeah
okay okay probably to generate a sample
that has a lower
see I didn't user what probability again
because I would become probably
generated sample with a lower
probability of profit generate a sample
with lower PDF than data given then data
yeah good
okay is that what we really say for
random seating and other functions
I can't use what seeding of
pseudo-random generators should be done
internally so we say I guess so
well why don't you check that I mean
you've been copying that right you
didn't trade that yes yeah I didn't
write that I just copied classify
actually some of our live streams
suggest instead anomaly indicators are
nominally boolean lists which is also
not crazy
yep might be wrong it doesn't matter
that it's long it's auto-completed
yeah the same forum classy father thank
you um what's the same for classifying
yeah yeah all right okay and actually
you know what
even the paid what did you say specify
what seeding of children imaginary it
all should be done inside the
operational functions that kind of
official wording okay all right okay go
find them you know this whole biz
about referring to another function is
really something that's gonna go away
but we need better tagging before we do
that there's just no excuse for sending
people to to that
amia told me that we should we can have
just our citizen just having their list
of methods here so do you think should
be done automatically what would you say
what we done semi-automatically we need
tagging to make sure that things don't
get out of sync
that's not part of the performance goal
here no it's really just about the
pre-processing
why are we giving the random seating
stuff here against has been copied it's
true it's always the same we shouldn't I
mean is it I don't know yes yes yes yes
automatic inherited cedar yes let's not
document it it's in random sitting so
it's okay volunteering so I should
remove it everywhere fine
okay looks very good alright so now
delete anomalies
okay looking good
okay so now there is a pretty lame
related link if I might say so it's a
very unconvincing right at links I don't
even discuss find anomalies in that
that's why we need your book Etienne how
is yours it's going to start very soon
twelve was a yeah starting start line um
actually we had some questions on the
livestream here do you have excess mass
and mass volume curves implemented I
don't know what that is for evaluating
the quality of the anomaly detector huh
excess mass and mass volume in mass
volume not sure what this means okay if
that we'd appreciate it
um okay and it also suggests nice
example be adding anomaly detection
benchmark CC eg UCSD as resource objects
and comparing find anomalies results by
method and against other published
results that sounds like a sensible
thing do we have anomaly detection
benchmarks in the data repository I've
heard of it so so I mean that would be
something for you I think to add in the
repository in the data repository some
again I mean is in the same office as me
again so that's good okay so that should
be straightforward
um okay which should we do like should
we do um dinner venues
what's up delete anomalies oh yeah okay
the last one oh and animate it's our
function as well maybe you could start I
mean whatever this one would be
straightforward I think actually we have
a lot of options
drops examples
actually that's not the right way to say
it because that suggests um gives a list
in which you can see yeah no no no a
list in which example I or in which
anomalous example are dropped which
examples consider it that a consider
anomalous yeah which in which the
example I that are considered anomalous
are dropped with respect to the others
well that are considered anomalous which
the example I that are considered
anomalous with respect to the list
you
you could put family just next to it
because there would be a bit of
repetition
what copy pasting you can open find
anomalies dodge page which is very
similar you have it there side by side
well it was a list in which the example
I
I just hate the fact how much the
example I
you
you
oh god this is horrible construction
that are considered anomalous have been
dropped
yeah no need to say okay okay yeah I
think the fourth paragraph you can
replace it with the fourth progress of
families
did you change stuff yeah and just put
delete anomalies instead of family isn't
that the same by the way with delete
anomalies I assume that we have yeah we
should probably have delete background
as another thing in here it's kind of
the opposite version of this
as always it pulled remove background
but it's from all backgrounds okay what
is that doing there that should probably
say anomaly delete anomalies right it
was just a copy-paste oh yes and oh by
the way I think second paragraph also we
change it right in front of my knees I
mean you could we could do it as at our
cell phone but can make sure that or
third paragraph actually so paragraph is
below the value exactly yeah
this we didn't change again it's just a
isn't random
he changed you changed what value
specific special and value specified for
I mean I would just you know I guess
okay again if we could take a whole
paragraph that would be yes yes yes yes
I know very weak for um okay do you want
me to relevant paper on anomaly rank and
whatever next is mascara and label of
salvation depending on the degree of
something to look at this looks
interesting there's a bunch of
interesting things here um you guys um
[Music]
Justin could you afford this to Etienne
please
you just sent it through yes um so we
have eleméry takeoff function now uh
right hold on hold on hold on hold on
till we finish on these well it's the
same as okay all right
okay great next oh by the way we didn't
have do we have to leave messing in here
we do not we should probably put that in
here so we did it that's good okay
what's next
last one for addiction which I don't see
listed and undefined anomalies which is
kind of unfortunate this doesn't return
anything to function but no I know but
it uses the to tell you yeah yeah okay
and we probably should put this in here
okay
now presents a function generated good
to do that for detecting if data is
anomalous for detecting whether data is
anomalous or not for detecting whether
data is anomalous or not what does it
returns terrific and solicited to be
anomalous and false otherwise removes is
that true if it considers data okay um
okay so here it's um
tests tests all of the data I why is it
smaller there's a problem in this
almighty yes you are becoming as
obsessive as I am yeah okay something's
up with that piece of formatting I agree
okay
okay so this is I do not like the wood
decision here
it's what we do for classify as well I
mean nobody will use it by the way
because the default okay fine
we coat the retailer and classify also
yeah yeah all right okay
another term for me especially for
classification yeah all right we changed
that and the other case right for what
there's no proper due ceremony okay
oh boy I'm running into the time for the
next meeting which unfortunately cannot
be postponed
not really it's kind of critical um okay
means don't follow me take sense that's
good alright look ahead have it open I'm
sorry okay Demerara probability since
you have it open and we just talked
about it so it's fresh in our brains
okay hold on let's just take a look at
these other things so the learned
distribution is gonna be a little
complicated I think let's just take a
look let's go ahead
a future eyes these at least so they get
in the builds hmm right again could you
take a good look at synthesized missing
that as well the feature is that yes I
think I did but um okay you started to
look at it a blend distribution it's
very similar on it's not missing values
in each distribution or is it in each
example you mean right missing I just
want to say it replaced example that are
missing you know it's like but the
example I that are missing no no it's
not that
exactly it's inside which example
there's some missing and there's like a
propose them yeah but it's about example
this one because does it replace the
actual missing itself yeah yeah but you
know I mean this would work as well you
know it's like everything is missing but
typically to be like a second example
second one okay we need to cover this
okay
so what I recommend let's try to get
this for tomorrow can do a 30-minute
meeting
yeah I'm unfortunate going to be in New
York with a smaller computer screen and
things tomorrow but I should be able to
do it nevertheless surely I should think
about that maybe I should take something
else um humph
okay alright so for people who are on
the live stream we are about to switch
to a different live stream where we are
talking about geometric computing
polygons with holes and other exciting
things would you like me to to UM for
these I'll commit these okay yep yes
okay I think there's a lot of repetition
as well I mean there would be I don't
think there's gonna be super hard yeah
and there may be a couple of bumps and I
I do would love to get those new guide
pages done as well
hmm um okay then I guess we can do an
hour yeah
okay see you guys soon and live stream
folk I'll I'll look forward to seeing
you and our geometric computing meeting
which starts basically now what's that
I'm committing thank you okay bye